if you live in a city you've probably
seen tens of thousands of passing faces
in your lifetime
but how many of those faces can you
recognize if you saw them again
new research suggests you could probably
recall around 5 000 of them
for the study the researchers divided
the faces people knew into two
categories
personally known faces like your
neighbor and public figures like
musicians
participants were given an hour to
recall faces in their personal lives
which meant that they could either form
a mental image of the face
or believe they would recognize the
person if they saw them
researchers provided several categories
to help jog the participants memories
friends commuters classmates colleagues
and more
next participants completed the same
recall task but with public figures
of course it's hard to come up with
every face in your memory so to account
for this
researchers created a database of over
3000 famous spaces to show participants
participants went through two versions
of the database with the same people
but different photographs if the
participant correctly identified the
person in both sets
scientists consider the yes response
valid
for every famous face the participant
recalled they recognized approximately
4.6 faces from the famous face database
using this ratio of recalled faces to
recognized faces
researchers estimated that on average
people know around five
thousand faces with the lower end of
recognition
at around a thousand and the higher end
a whopping ten
thousand faces how many faces do you
think are stored in your memory
[Music]
you